on this friday night donald trump's
search warrant unsealed
there may be fire along with the smoke
new details reveal the scope of the
fbi's unprecedented operation what it
could mean for the former u.s president
they'll decide whether or not there's
the basis to charge someone with a crime
salman rushdie attacked the acclaimed
author's shocking stabbing on stage the
literary world reacts to the violent
assault of a polarizing figure plus
press conference derailed
totally crazy
doug ford's buzzworthy moment on
national tv i just swallowed the beach
global national with farah nasser
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us tonight we're learning more about
what was in the 11 sets of highly
classified documents taken from former
u.s president donald trump's florida
home on monday fbi agents descended on
trump's mar-a-lago mansion with a search
warrant specifically looking for
government materials trump allegedly
took from the white house when he left
office and what investigators found
suggests trump is under investigation
for potentially serious violations of
u.s law let's get right to our
washington bureau chief jackson proskow
jackson what was in those boxes
well pharah we don't have a lot of
specifics at this point just a general
idea that there was a lot of classified
information and it all suggests there's
a serious probe underway into the former
president and his conduct
the search warrant shows the fbi
recovered 11 sets of classified
documents from donald trump's home some
categorized as top secret among the most
sensitive and valuable u.s intelligence
meant to only be viewed in secure
government facilities another item was
labeled info regarding the president of
france along with pictures and boxes of
documents
a report from the washington post goes
further suggesting the fbi's primary
target was documents related to nuclear
weapons what we'll see happen over the
next few days is doj will first review
the evidence that they seized from
mar-a-lago they'll decide whether or not
there's a basis based on what they found
to charge someone with a crime the
unsealed search warrant also reveals
serious legal jeopardy for trump the
department of justice is investigating
violations of three u.s laws including
the espionage act for gathering or
transmitting defense information and
potential obstruction of justice for
destruction alteration or falsification
of records in a federal investigation
the search warrant was authorized by a
federal court upon the required finding
of probable cause in a post on his truth
social platform trump called the nuclear
weapons issue a hoax and without
evidence accused the fbi of planting
information
later he claimed all the documents were
declassified the fbi raid of president
trump is a complete abuse and overreach
of its authority republicans continue to
stand by their man suggesting trump is
the victim of an overzealous and
political fbi
notably some are now making room for the
possibility of serious misconduct by the
former president demanding more
information before rendering judgment
was it nuclear
was it
heck maybe it was aliens
that's the point we don't know we're
asking them to tell us specifics aren't
contained in the documents unsealed
friday and the underlying affidavit
remains sealed likely to protect the
ongoing investigation and any
confidential sources who may be working
with the justice department still
unknown the former president's
underlying motivation for leaving office
with boxes of government material
these are some very serious allegations
espionage obstruction destruction now
jackson trump and his allies are arguing
that the materials were declassified is
there any proof of those claims
well we don't know that for a fact there
would certainly be a paper trail if that
process had been undertaken but i think
the bigger picture thing here to keep in
mind is that those highest levels of
classification cannot be unilaterally
declassified by a president often
there's an agency review process it's a
multi-step process and there are
multiple parties involved so trump
himself may have not been able to
declassify things related for example to
nuclear weapons if that is in fact uh in
the documents that were recovered from
mar-a-lago
all right i know we'll be getting more
details in the coming days jackson
prosco in washington thank you
acclaimed and polarizing author salman
rushdie was stabbed in the neck today
while he was on stage at a convention in
western new york the governor of new
york says the 75-year-old is alive and
he's getting the care he needs and the
suspect is in custody rushdie has faced
death threats in the past he spent years
with a bounty on his head hiding from
iran because of his writing tonight eric
sorenson looks at that and this latest
attack
it was a scene of chaos in the normally
tranquil setting of new york state's
chautauqua institution salman rushdie
about to speak was attacked by a man who
jumped on stage says this witness
repeated fist strokes into his chest and
neck
apparently he had a knife i just
devastated at
seeing this happen to someone i respect
the attacker was subdued and is in
custody several members of the staff at
the institution and audience members
rushed the suspect and took him to the
ground the suspect has been identified
as haiti matar age 24
from fairview new jersey rushdie was
flown by helicopter to a nearby hospital
where he was in surgery late friday
afternoon here's an individual who has
spent decades
speaking truth to power
someone who's been out there
unafraid
despite the threats a renowned novelist
rushdie was forced into hiding more than
30 years ago after writing the book the
satanic verses it had provocative themes
about the prophet muhammad that many
muslims considered blasphemous rusty's
effigy and his books were burned iran's
supreme leader ayatollah khomeini issued
a fatwa calling for rusty's death
for years the author appeared in public
only with heavy security he later spoke
of the need to stay in the public eye
it's clear that
you have to defend
things you don't agree with otherwise
what is free speech if it's only for
people that you sort of agree with in
1992 bob ray was ontario's premier one
of the first political leaders in the
world to publicly embrace rusty who was
grateful canadian writer margaret atwood
like rushdie has been an outspoken
advocate for free speech and literature
calling rusty courageous we're all
extremely sorry that something like this
has happened but it is a wake-up call to
us that if we really want to live in a
democracy we need to defend
freedom of expression and we need to do
it vigilantly so i take the subway you
know over time the prolific writer has
lived with much less security and put
aside the fear of death threats what
helped me come out of that was beginning
to fight back and i think you know when
you're fighting back you don't you don't
feel like a package in the corner
waiting for somebody to come and get you
but in iran a three million dollar
bounty reportedly remained on rushdie
some believing the ayatollah's original
verdict was irrevocable at chautauqua
rushdie was just about to speak about
freedom of expression and america as a
safe haven for artists in exile
erik sorensen global news toronto
in montenegro 12 people are dead
following a mass shooting in the
country's western region six others were
injured including a police officer
witnesses say a local man opened fire
shooting people at random reportedly
following a family dispute the
34-year-old gunman was eventually shot
dead by police
when russia invaded ukraine in late
february it also launched a parallel
propaganda war to try to blur the lines
about what was happening on the ground
in ukraine in an effort to divide the
world of the truth tonight our jeff
semple looks into russia's notorious
troll factory that is flooding social
media with lies
and is also taking aim at canadians
this canadian veteran recently returned
home to quebec after narrowly escaping
ukraine with his life
he was fighting in the dawn bass back in
april when his volunteer unit was
ambushed by a russian tank there was
this huge explosion and i saw the
shrapnels flying in front of me the
canadian sniper known as wally spent two
months in the battlefield where he also
got caught in a propaganda war the
russians are not sophisticated fighters
after providing interviews to western
journalists back in march wally's story
went viral russia responded first with
posts suggesting he'd been killed then
state media wrote that wally had
condemned ukraine's military is a
terrible disappointment full of chaos
looting and incompetence they pretty
much took a few words i did and deform
it just enough so it kind of makes sense
so it sounds like i'm terribly
disappointed which i'm not what he
actually said to a french newspaper was
that war itself is a disappointment
particularly for inexperienced western
volunteers who initially rushed to
ukraine looking for adventure
wally says the ukrainian soldiers he met
on the front line were anything but
disappointing i really do think
they are the most courageous soldier i
ever saw personally but those twisted
facts and misquotes were heavily
promoted online by a small army of
professional internet trolls like senja
klochkova
at the start of the war the russian
journalist went undercover inside a
russian troll factory a new operation
called cyber front z
when i was hired they told me this is a
temporary enterprise to support russia's
army in cyberspace clochkova told global
news she says they used fake accounts
often with western names to post
comments on youtube and across social
media praising putin and condemning
those who oppose the war
she says the people in charge are linked
to this former now notorious troll
factory in saint petersburg which was
accused of meddling in the 2016 u.s
presidential election
the operation employed a hundred people
per shift she says they were paid a
thousand dollars a month and were
required to publish at least 200
comments every day those comments
pushing the kremlin's narrative that
russia is liberating ukraine from nazis
were then reinforced by russian state
media it's impossible to defeat russia
evgeny popov is one of russia's most
popular tv hosts he claims for example
that atrocities committed by russian
forces against ukrainian civilians in
bucha were fake russia
have no connections to those dead bodies
when asked for evidence he falsely
claimed that it took ukraine five days
to reveal civilians had been massacred
and that the victims were never
identified give us names give us some
names give us a family global news and
other world media outlets have
identified many names of civilians
killed in bucha but a quick simple
online search also turns up articles
referencing those russian conspiracies a
testament to how effectively the kremlin
has flooded the internet with
disinformation burying the truth no
matter the cost
jeff semple global news
it's too early to say that monkey pox
cases are plateauing but health
officials are encouraged by what may be
the beginning of a positive trend
there's some early signs of a slowing
down of that
accelerated
epi curve so we're not
the cases are not increasing at the
speed of which they were increasing at
the beginning of the outbreak
dr tam adds they still need to collect a
few more weeks of data to determine if
cases are plateauing meanwhile canada
broke the 1 000 confirmed cases of
monkey pox threshold this week which has
officials urging continued vigilance the
vast majority of cases involve men who
have sex with men but tam stresses
anyone can contract or transmit monkey
pox approximately fifty thousand of the
nearly one hundred thousand distributed
doses of the monkey pox vaccine have
been administered so far
navigating canada's changing housing
market coming up with some markets
cooling experts way in on which mortgage
options may be best for you
the housing market looks a lot different
today than it did during the buying
frenzy throughout the height of the
pandemic home prices and activity have
cooled and many economists think that
there is more correction to come and
gaviola has more on the changing
variables and how to navigate this
challenging market
canada's housing market has defied
expectations throughout the pandemic
with an eye-popping run-up in prices
which only began to cool as the central
bank jacked up interest rates starting
in march this the last two years have
shown us anything and is that you know
predictions can be wrong most of the
time nick hill is a real estate investor
with money in a handful of projects in
ontario for some he went with a static
variable rate mortgage which means
monthly payments don't change when the
bank of canada increases its benchmark
lending rate what changes is the ratio
of interest versus principal he's paying
with more going towards interest
what's really started to happen is
the cash flow on these properties has
started to dissipate
and i'm looking at that
not happy however i'm looking at that as
a temporary
thing variable rates has historically
always performed better than fixed rates
over a long period of time his
investment horizon is long-term though
so he's not losing sleep over it with a
myriad of changing considerations making
the right choice for you can be a
challenge daniel fosh who does a real
estate podcast with hill suggests buyers
do their own stress test including a
worst-case financial scenario to fully
understand their financial cushion and
risk tolerance examine the total cost of
the interest that you'd pay over the
course of a mortgage term and look at
that side by side with the
you know three different interest rates
or mortgage products that you might be
looking at during the pandemic the
popularity of variable rate mortgages
soared but they may not be the right fit
especially for households with little
financial flexibility i think that this
is a symptom
of a housing market that is basically in
crisis and people were chasing prices
personal finance expert rubina ahmed
hawk suggests preparing for another
hefty interest rate hike expected in
september
that's a really scary position to be in
whether you're a seller or a buyer
because it does just create that
unpredictability with so much up in the
air it's never been more important for
prospective buyers and sellers to do
their homework before making a move
ann caviola global news toronto
rogers and shaw have finalized an
agreement to sell freedom mobile paving
the way for a merger of canada's biggest
telecom companies
rogers will sell the shaw-owned wireless
carrier to videotron which is owned by
quebecois for 2.85 billion dollars the
telecom giant hopes the deal will
appease federal regulator concerns about
its proposed takeover of shaw rogers and
shaw claim the combination of freedom
and videotron will create a strong
fourth national carrier the agreement is
subject to regulatory approvals and the
closing of the rogers shaw merger and if
you're a telus customer you could soon
see a new fee on your bill the telecom
giant has a pride to the crtc to add a
1.5 surcharge starting this fall the fee
would only apply to customers paying
with a credit card outside of quebec
telus says the average increase would be
around two dollars a month and customers
can avoid the fee by paying via debit or
through a bank
ahead another round of flash floods tear
through las vegas
now that's not a royal flush that's what
looks like a waterfall pouring through a
casino rooftop in las vegas after heavy
rain triggered flash flooding that
completely swamped the desert city's
famous strip the scene is a flashback to
just a few weeks ago when another severe
thunderstorm rolled through
from heavy flooding to fierce fires
crews from across europe are being
rushed to france to help tame towering
flames tearing through the country's
pine forests
a monstrous wildfire south of bordeaux
that destroyed swaths of land in july
erupted again this week with another
heat wave scorching the region and
elsewhere including spain and the uk
since the beginning of the year nearly
60 000 hectares of forest has been wiped
out in france the wildfires have
produced nearly a million metric tons of
carbon from june to august which is
almost equal to the annual carbon
dioxide emissions from seven hundred and
ninety thousand cars
actor ann heach has died from injuries
she sustained in a fiery car crash last
week heish was declared legally dead
today her body is still on life support
for organ donation the 53-year-old was
critically injured after crashing her
car into a house in los angeles on
august 5th police say an initial blood
sample revealed the presence of drugs in
her system haiti rose to fame in the
early 1990s on television and films like
six days seven nights and donnie brasco
she had a high profile relationship with
ellen degeneres shortly after the
comedian came out as gay the mother of
two was open about her lifelong
struggles with her mental health heish
continued to have an active film and tv
career
[Music]
not coming from the
uh government per se but the premier
it's coming from the health sector
holy christ
i just swallowed the bee oh my god
christ i knew that little bugger
are you okay
i'm good he's down here buzzing around
right now he's a lot of he has a lot of
real estate now if that was in the clip
okay this is going to be replayed over
and over again and that just made colin
de mello's day he's going to be laughing
all the way back to the city
oh i'm sure he was and he joins us now
colin demelo is global's queen's park
bureau chief at the ontario legislature
colin great to see you
you know he's used to stinging criticism
doug ford but this was something else
oh pharah this was a surreal moment and
what was supposed to be a very serious
news conference about the health care
system in ontario all of a sudden out of
nowhere the premier started gagging and
choking trying to dig a bee
out of his mouth never in political
history
i think have we ever seen in this
country a premier ingesting and perhaps
digesting a bee
live on tv during a news conference the
entire uh
crowd that was gathered there from
reporters to his staff were in stunned
silence we didn't know what to think a
lot of people started thinking about the
premier's uh well-being
and then thinking what would we do if
this happened to us i think a lot of us
were pretty horrified at the idea and
i'm sure social media was a buzz with
this
oh yes this is a buzzworthy moment for
sure we were there to talk about the
privatization of the health care system
the premier joked well maybe he might
need to go to the health care system the
hospital to get that b removed a lot of
people on twitter firing back saying hey
when he gets there maybe the ers might
actually be closed in ontario
never a dull day in ontario politics
colin de mello thank you so much
unbelievable
see this is why masks are a good idea
that is global national for this friday
night thank you so much for spending
part of your evening with us
we're going to leave you tonight with a
little bit more of premier ford because
well why not
holy christ he's wedged to my throat
sorry guys a little bugger got away in
there
i'm okay he's buzzing in there
man he went right down the hatch okay
guys
this is a classic okay
this is holy chris
sorry
oh this is a good one i'm going to be
howling tonight watching this tape
neither garcia will be back at the
anchor desk tomorrow until monday take
care of yourselves and each other good
night
[Music]
holy